imagine computers that can read your
mind
and brain implants that control
computers by thought alone everybody is
fascinated about the idea of potentially
being able to control things just using
their mind this technology could
revolutionize everything from astronauts
in space
to care for the severely paralyzed he'll
save his life by turning himself into
the world's first cyborg the gap between
the virtual and Real Worlds is closing
but how long till headsets and screens
disappear
is not the real world
and the Matrix is no longer fiction
[Music]
this is the headquarters of vario a
startup company based in Finland
it might look like they've created a
typical VR experience but it's not
vario has created a headset which is
changing how people interact with
virtual and computer-generated Worlds by
changing how their brains engage with
them here in this example we have a
Volvo car based on a cad model that was
just transformed into fully
photorealistic accurate replica of the
actual design model
various groundbreaking headset is built
using Advanced Eye tracking technology
this means only the part of the image
the eye is looking at needs to be
processed and with no perceivable lag it
feels realistic
we design Optics and displays that make
it possible to see in the same
resolution as your own IC
this means that whatever we replicate
looks exactly the same as it would look
like in the real world
photorealism is one of the first steps
towards convincing our brains that
compute generated simulations are real
but achieving this will also require
improvements to devices called brain
computer interfaces or bcis
the vario headset uses hardware and
software from a company called open BCI
a BCA is a brain computer interface so
it's essentially a way for the brain to
directly interface with computers by
reading out signals from the brain
[Music]
the term brain computer interface was
coined in the 1970s in California the
aim was to control external objects
using signals from the brain but it's
only within the last 20 years that
researchers have started to pull this
off turn right
and Fire
today there are two kinds of bcis the
first type are called non-invasive and
can take the form of portable devices
using non-invasive ways of reading out
brain activity those signals are
directly translated into ways of
controlling computers whether it's a
video game or it's a robotic arm or any
sort of machine
[Music]
to make computers better at reading
brain signals scientists need to get
better at understanding the brain
you can't put a BCA on think to yourself
do I want to eat you know fried chicken
or a sandwich or a salad for lunch and
then think of it and then order it
online you don't have clear brain
regions for fried chicken versus salad
in the brain
if we know what the brain activity is
that we're looking for in the brain
region then we can use that signal to
control a BCI
[Music]
improving the understanding of the brain
could lead to the type of BCI featured
in the film Ready Player One
set in 2045 it shows much of humanity
Escaping The Real World by using
headsets which fully immerse their
brains in the Oasis a near perfect
virtual reality simulation
getting the design of non-invasive bci's
right is vital to fulfilling their
potential
some find devices like headsets
impractical and bulky
[Music]
but scientists are bringing designs down
to size on top you can see one of the
early prototypes of attention view
glasses which have a sensors on the back
of the ears Dr Natalia cosmina is a
technologist at MIT who is working on a
series of new designs in conjunction
with NASA we have a project with NASA
about optimizing performance of
astronauts
the project is using this technology to
read the brain activity of astronauts on
missions to the International Space
Station in order to monitor their health
and performance so it's a suite of
different variable Wireless
sense in devices that can pick up brain
activity eye movements and those can be
put in the form factor of a pair of
glasses
we're gonna try on a pair of attentive
view glasses so we can pick up the brain
activity using these electrodes the
attentive view glasses allow someone to
answer questions by simply thinking of
the answer
the computer is able to understand their
answer by recording their brain waves so
what Kareem will need to do using only
his brain activity to give an answer to
this question so do you like it here
yes
okay did we get it right I assume yes
it's a technology that offers great
promise on Earth as well as in space for
example for people suffering from
neurogenerative disorders like ALS which
causes a loss in the ability to
communicate what we actually are doing
we are providing them with this basic
education the caregiver can ask a
question to the patient and the patient
can respond yes no
[Music]
these devices also have the potential to
physically alter the brain and change
how it works
try not to think
to think of and just rest your head for
10 seconds okay okay Professor suck Lee
Liu is a neuroscientist who has been
working in this field for over 10 years
over time if you train or practice with
a BCI a lot you can actually see changes
in both the brain activity patterns that
people have and in the brain structures
using a BCA can not only replace or
serve as a compensatory role for
replacing function but it can actually
also help to rehabilitate or restore
brain networks and Pathways and it's
essentially like a like a brain training
sort of tool
one day the world may wake up to the
reality of another kind of brain
computer interface
evasive kind when the Matrix will no
longer be just a Hollywood dream
invasive bcis promise the future merger
of brains and computers through surgical
implants
it's early days for this technology and
so far testing has mostly been done on
animals rather than humans
[Music]
like this monkey pager pager simply
thinks about moving his hand up or down
with electrodes surgically inserted into
his brain he is able to play the game
pong simply by thinking about moving his
hand up or down and sending brain
signals to the computer
the experiment was conducted by Elon
musk's company neurolink
neurolink says its ultimate aim is to
improve the lives of humans with
impaired abilities
however its experiments have proved
controversial protesters lining up
calling for neural links animal testing
labs to be shut down
the company says it has euthanized eight
monkeys but insists it has followed the
law at all times
invasive bcis can also pose ethical and
health risks for humans so they actually
have to cut your skull open and then
implant an electrode and then put the
skull back on
despite this many consider these
implants to be the most promising path
to removing the gap between the virtual
and Real Worlds
the most accurate tend to be the ones
that are implanted in the brain the
upside is that you're reading directly
from neural populations so the cells in
the brain that are actually firing
invasive bcis have the potential to
integrate human biology with technology
in unprecedented ways
and scientists are slowly moving in this
direction
in 2018 scientist Peter Scott Morgan
offered his own body to his profession
he suffered from motor neurone disease
and allowed surgeons to implant various
chips into his body in the hope of
extending his life whatever happens we
will learn from it
and we will do it better the next time
the pioneering operations helped him
live for another four years until his
death in 2022.
the brain remains one of Humanity's
greatest enigmas
technology that melds the brain with
computers opens up new possibilities
highlighting both how powerful the brain
is and how little it is understood while
scientists are a long way from
understanding its Secrets there are
grounds for both hope and concern
it's a very scary thought when you start
looking into into what you could do when
you're directly interfacing the brain
yet at the same time you you can
completely understand that this is a
trajectory we are on
I'm Tom Standish Deputy editor at The
Economist if you'd like to learn more
about this topic click on the link
opposite and if you'd like to watch more
of our now and next series click on the
other link thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe